pour commencer cette immersion nous
sommes aux clayes-sous-bois nous nous
rendons à la boutique secret d'intérieur
spécialisé dans la vente de décoration
pour la maison
contraint de fermer avec ce second
confinement dominique duguet sa gérante
a dû s'adapter venez on va la rencontrer
[Musique]
le
bonjour dominique duguet bonjour nicolas
bienvenue chez secret d'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
merci de nous accueillir votre boutique
vous êtes actuellement sur un
fonctionnement click and collect oui
comment ça se passe que dans quelle
situation vous êtes la situation du
magasin d'à très bien en fait après le
premier confinement on a récupéré tout
notre chiffre d'affaires les clients
étaient très nombreux à venir
bon maintenant par contre la situation
est catastrophique le mois de novembre
le mois de décembre sont des chiffres
énormes
on n'est pas du tout du tout dans la
même situation qu'au premier confirme
c'est bien plus grave
comment vous vous êtes adapté du coup
face à cette situation eh bien on a fait
un site très très rapidement en trois
jours on a mis six cent cinquante
produits sur le net on avait pas de site
de vente on a travaillé j'ai deux
alternant qui travaillent avec moi plus
ma famille on s'est tous mis à terre ce
fameux site et dont deux cuillères nous
faisons le click and collect du coup la
digitalisation c'est quelque chose que
vous avez mis en place par rapport à la
situation
riboud a travaillé sur le net c'est
parce que j'aime moi ce que je veux
faire c'est le contact client sait
conseiller mes clients les recevoir dans
mon magasin
mais vu la situation catastrophique je
me suis mis très très vite sur internet
alors comment ça s'est passé vous pouvez
nous expliquer comment vous avez mis en
place des choses et puis vous avez aussi
dit quelque chose d'innovant en plaçant
oui alors tout d'abord j'ai beaucoup
communiqué sur les réseaux sociaux pour
annoncer que j'allais faire un site
internet mais alternant mon mari et moi
même on s'est mis à récupérer toutes les
photos chez les fournisseurs
on est venu faire des photos dans le
magasin et on a tout installé sur le
site
donc c'est très très longue parce qu'il
faut donner les désignations des
produits les prix etc
et c'est très très long alors
l'innovation alors là j'y tiens vraiment
à tout le monde connait les 18 euros
moi je vais faire le visio shopping et
je commence dès aujourd'hui à faire un
10 e shopping
en fait le but le client est chez lui
très
installé très confortablement et moi je
lui présente tous les produits en visio
et me demande ce qu'ils souhaitent et en
fonction de ses besoins
je répond à ces questions c'est ma vie
le magasin c'est ma vie et donc j'ai
vraiment vraiment envie de continuer à
travailler dans ce magasin merci
dominique duguet avec plaisir